welcome I'm pleased to have with me
today a Wall Street insider and renowned
journalist author and speaker Noemi
Prince having worked at Chase Manhattan
Bank Lehman Brothers Bear Stearns and as
a managing director at Goldman Sachs
homie Prince had a distinguished career
on Wall Street and has only
distinguished herself further by sharing
her expertise via the written and spoken
word widely sought after by major media
outlets Nomi has written a number of
acclaimed works including other people's
money
it takes a pillage in black Tuesday she
joins me today to discuss her most
recent work all the president's bankers
the hidden alliances that drive American
power know me welcome and
congratulations on such a fabulous book
as we take a look into Washington Wall
Street and the families that have had
such an enormous impact on our nation
and the world thank you so much Larry
thank you for that lovely introduction
as well my pleasure and it was very
easily done again given the the fabulous
career that you've had both on Wall
Street and now off Wall Street in the
literary world so it's truly a pleasure
to have you
let's dive right in I this is truly an
incredible and I would say an
unparalleled written history of the the
relationships between Wall Street the
large banks that have dominated our
nation and Washington what motivated you
to take on such an incredible amount of
effort and exercise to produce this book
a slight bit of insanity I think in the
amount of time I spent working on it and
the intensity but but actually the novel
I had written black Tuesday which was a
historical novel on the crash of 29 had
a scene in it that I had researched
slightly nothing near the research I did
for this book on six bankers that had
gotten together at the house of Morgan
on 23 Wall Street one noon to decide to
try and save the markets that were
crashing around them in late October
1929 by themselves and a fellow named
Tom Lamont who was the acting chair of
the morgan bank at the time his
chair jack morgan was gallivanting
around the world he was elsewhere
gathered five other bankers together the
most powerful families of bankers
running the most powerful banks on Wall
Street to say we need to do something to
save these markets and they decided with
just 20 minutes to throw in twenty five
million dollars each into a buying pool
tell one of their guys to go and buy a
lot of stock and basically by themselves
try to boost this market that was
falling all around them and I just found
that really fasting this idea these big
six banks and I started to notice that
well today we have six banks and I
looked back in time just cursory
analysis and there were six banks a
hundred years ago in the panic of 1907
and they were all largely the same banks
in the first part of the century also
the same families now similar legacies
but I started to say well what is that
relationship and I was fascinated and
general with other works I had done with
the political association of bankers and
so what I decided to do is take a look
at the history of that period and look
at the real relationships between six
bankers whoever the most important one
was at any point in time in our nation's
history during that century and what
their connections were to presidents and
what I found because I didn't know that
every single president from Teddy
Roosevelt through Barack Obama had
strong associations not always with the
six key bankers but certainly with a
subset at least of six bankers through
through documents and letters and phone
calls and all sorts of other forms of
communication as well as social
connections through clubs and Harvard
and other types of places where they
would meet clearly relationships are
everything I and whether people want to
promote those relationships or not but
King let's let's take a step and go
behind the scenes I and you know could
you take us you know into your research
where did you go
who did you meet to to you know unearth
some truly incredible material yeah I
decided to go to all of the presidential
libraries to make the research very even
and always start from the president out
to whether they had associations with
particular bankers so for every period
time I wanted to make sure that at least
had the appropriate historical events
that would have occurred at that time
for example I used to joke with my
editor Karl Bromley at nation books and
I would say I just don't want to forget
that World War one happened you know I
don't forget about Vietnam so what I did
was I had a sort of outline of major
events that happened and each president
of course and Treasury secretary and I
went to all the archives all the
presidential our archives where the
material existed throughout the country
for example I was at Abilene Kansas and
in one hot August working with the
archives of President Dwight Eisenhower
from where I went to Independence
Missouri to look at the archives of
President Truman I started actually in
Austin with LBJ and I went back to
Austin several times throughout the
period of research because I found that
that period very critical in terms of
relationships and changing attitudes in
America between presidents and bankers
citizens and presidents and so forth and
I really just dug in deep and I didn't
know what I would find in some cases I
had to submit FOIA Freedom of
Information acts to unearth certain
documents for the or the more recent
presidents that had not been unearthed
yet in some cases for example the Reagan
Library in California the archivist
really kind of took my project to heart
and and spent some of her own time
really trying to look for documents for
me as I was sitting there going through
the boxes that I had I'm when you do
research they bring out carts and boxes
and it's almost like a race you know
you're going through the boxes you have
what can I find and and there could be
anything in a box with Harry Truman
there could be anything from letters
about you know why did you drop the
atomic bomb two letters from bankers
saying thank you very much for your
support and him writing back to them
saying I couldn't have done it without
you and so there's there's all sorts of
things that you find and you just get
into this mode of being in that time and
that president with those people going
through just just an immense amount of
documents and then and then sort of
typing everything up while you're there
typing it up at night editing throughout
the process and then sort of going on to
the next location in the next president
were there any libraries that were
that you deemed to be somewhat reluctant
to share information well a lot of until
Reagan actually from FDR through the
Reagan Library era there was there's a
certain code under which everything is
classified you know for military
information for finance information
economics personal relationships and
it's a very clear code with very clear
identifications and it's very almost
easy taxes information of the Carter
Library for example I went there shortly
after the film Argo came out and there
had been apparently a whole team of like
Argo researchers down there slightly
before that movie looking up information
about the Iran hostage crisis and what
happened and they have this this cool
rack system where you could go in and
actually look digitally it a lot of
documents not every library has that but
then when some of the more recent
libraries for example the Clinton
Library there's very little already
opened and part of that's because there
is such an immense amount of information
and plus now you have email and
everything needs to go through security
clearances and it's in a different code
after Reagan came in the codes changed
so it was a lot harder to find
information the reason I could find it
in the Reagan Library was because the
archivist had worked at one of the prior
libraries so she kind of knew the
difference between the new codes and the
old codes she could help me but I still
have ways out standing at the Clinton
Library
I still have ways outstanding at the
George Bush Library in Texas and of
course the George W Bush library just
opened so III didn't have the
opportunity to look at anything there
and Obama's still in office yep yep was
there a point in time where the the
picture started to or the started to
sharpen in terms of the the nature of
some of these relationships where it
really where you started to realize wow
this actually goes deeper than perhaps
either yourself as well as the public
would have imagined or might even still
imagine yeah and because I didn't really
start at the beginning of the
president's I kind of worked more on
geography and flight patterns
I was doing a little bit of jumping back
and forth and so for example yeah I will
go to the LBJ library and I would see
his relationship with Sidney Weinberg
who was the chairman of Goldman Sachs at
the time and then I would be at the FDR
library and see how they had been very
close friends because something LBJ had
said to Sidney Weinberg in the 60s ie we
were both FDR men back then it's so good
to have you on my team again even of
course he wasn't in office anywhere they
were just on the same team and then when
I went to the FDR library to see for
example the beginnings of that
relationship so a lot of times starting
in the middle of history and going
backwards allowed me to then catch up in
the middle and go to those same bankers
and see what their relationships worth
all the presidents in between and when I
found in many instances if you had a
relationship with one president you had
a relationship with many and then going
back further in time I mentioned in the
beginning how Tom Lamont was the
chairman at JPMorgan during the crash in
1929 I knew that from black Tuesday what
I didn't know and I found this out when
I was at the FDR library in Hyde Park
which is very near where I grew up as
well I got there as a kid but certainly
not on research expeditions he actually
had rented out his townhouse on East
65th Street in Manhattan to Tomas Lomond
for several years while if Dr was the
assistant Navy secretary under Woodrow
Wilson so the tie that happened after
the crashing into the Great Depression
when FDR was then president had started
way back they had both gone to Harvard
they had both been involved with the
Crimson Harvard paper over there Tom
Lamont had actually been one of the
editors a very young editor of that
paper when he was at Harvard and they
had a very long history which then
lasted through several decades and so he
just kind of there was this onion effect
where you would just layer and layer and
it went a sister II going forward it was
history going back a lot of decades and
relationships in between so the
relationships really went from not only
the business and the political but often
into the social as well Ben yeah exactly
when at one of the other bankers for
example Winthrop Aldrich who ran chase
during the Great Depression was was a
friend of the Roosevelts and he was all
so yachtsman one of his boats won the
American Cup back in 1930 or something
like that so yes so there was there was
all that going on back then as well and
and FDR and his sons also were
interested in that and so and of course
JP Morgan had you know a tremendous
yacht at the time sort of the equivalent
of what we have now with Larry Ellison
yeah and so there was there was similar
tastes as well that that came into play
and so there were social gatherings I'm
going forward in history for example in
1938 FDR had at this point appointed a
well known name well known family named
Joseph Kennedy to be the first head of
the SEC when it was created and also he
appointed him to be the UK ambassador in
the late 30s after Joe Kennedy was head
of the SEC so Nigel Kennedy is off in
England he's having a gala coming-out
party very lovely huge social event
where his daughter Kathleen who
unfortunately died young as part of
another Kennedy tragedy but John F
Kennedy a young John F Kennedy was at
that event David Rockefeller who was
part of a long history of industrial
financial family strength was also there
in fact he somewhat dated Kathleen
Kennedy for a minute back at the time
and so the ties these connections were
it went through all sorts of social
events that you know people wouldn't be
involved so again it's not just the
social in the individuals but as you're
just alluding to the strength of the
families as well and those family ties
that run deep I mean the Morgan the
Rockefeller these Kennedys mm-hmm the
Roosevelt's James was about FDR's father
and JP Morgan the immensely Famer famous
and powerful JP Morgan created together
among a few other established families
the Metropolitan Club in New York which
was a very exclusive club where these
men could get together and talk about
affairs of the day and decide things in
a very small tight environment what is
on what is on royalty almost it really
was I mean when you think about even the
terms today that
used for you know sentient throne of the
hierarchy of you know the terms that we
use even in industry and banking today
you know who's going to who's the heir
to my throne of JPMorgan Chase with even
the terminology has that sense of
monarchy to it and certainly back in the
beginning of the 20th century and
throughout a good portion of it there
was really three or four families that
that were most instrumental in running
the top three financial institutions in
the country that also had the tightest
personal and political financial
connections with the presidents over
that time although in some cases a
difference is that these people don't
get elected they are their family
appointed one of the other families the
Stillman's who were running National
City Bank back in the early part of the
20th century and of course National City
Bank is now part of what we know a
Citigroup
you know he had two daughters they
married two sons of one of the
Rockefellers and together they produced
a Stillman Rockefeller that then ran
what was Citibank in the late 50s and
early 60s so you know these these lines
blood is thicker than water right
absolutely and sometimes money
sure or connected yeah yep well I guess
when they combine all of them you know
blood money power becomes is Game of
Thrones it's a game of Thrones and ends
up in exactly an incredible book let's
go back to towards the beginning of the
book set the scene for us please we go
off the coast of Georgia to a place
called Jekyll Island what happened who
was involved what came out of it and
were the motivations of the people in
your opinion where they truly pure and
sincere so there's a lot there they were
sincere for themselves know what
happened was at Jekyll Island in
November of 1910 there was a meeting
that was called by Senator Nelson
Aldrich Aldridge's were also very famous
powerful political family that
integrated into being a political
financial family and Nelson Aldrich as
the Senate Finance Chairman was tasked
with trying to create a central bank
that would appease the public as well as
past politically in Washington and
reason for that was there had been a
panic of a major bank panic in 1907 a
few years before that at which Teddy
Roosevelt had asked JP Morgan to get his
people together to try and save the
markets it's a little bit different
today where the government works to save
the bankers and it was the government
calling the bankers to try and help the
general economy and after that panic and
after JP Morgan got a bunch of his
friends together to decide which banks
or trust companies could live or die and
how much money each had to pony up to
back them up he was a little afraid and
thought you know I I don't want to have
to do this exercise again I would prefer
a central bank as well so the bankers
adopted this idea of having a central
bank to help subsidize or stabilize them
so that they wouldn't have to put their
own money in whether or not they had
caused the panic and from a government
standpoint Teddy Roosevelt and talk
about it so much but when Taft came in
as president he very much puts this idea
of having a central bank and Nelson
Aldrich and the Aldrin's family was
close to the Taft family and they
basically decided that they would do
these expeditions into Europe see what
was going on with the Bank of England
see what was going on and with France
and see if America couldn't duplicate
something that was more American but
still enabled them to have this powerful
central bank to back bankers and also to
back the emerging currency that was
going to be the most powerful currency
in the world the dollar so fast forward
a few years of fact-finding and you know
traveling around Europe and Nelson
Aldrich went around with James Stillman
quite quite often who was the head of
National City Bank and he got back and
got support by lots of document level
Jekyll Island happened because it was
time to make it official and JP Morgan
said you know you need to do this
somewhere somewhat privately only after
Nelson Aldrich was hit by a trolley car
on Madison Avenue who was in New York he
was discussing things with bankers his
son Winthrop Eldridge lived in New York
as well and he got hit on 60th Street by
this Madison Avenue trolley car so he
was a bit convalesced it had been
planned to have a big meeting at his
estate in Rhode Island
but now he's in New York he's with the
bankers and Morgan has this club
membership at the Jekyll Island Club off
the coast of Georgia and really
sponsored which is something I found out
when I went myself to Jekyll Island
sponsored this six people again to work
together at in secrecy away from eyes to
bash out this idea of the Fed now the
sort of cloak-and-dagger stuff I think
is a little bit exaggerated I mean it
wasn't like you had paparazzi sort of
flying in and a Jekyll Island it's it's
generally at the time it was off of the
coast you couldn't really get there and
you certainly couldn't drive there and
they were posts of men watching if boats
came in to make sure that they couldn't
even dock near the Jekyll Island Club so
it was it was a pretty secure place
already anyway and that's where they
bashed out the plan and at the end of
them bashing out this plan Nelson's
going to go back to Washington to
present it to the Senate and what
happens was he was still not feeling
well from a trolley car situation and so
what occurred was two of the bankers who
had been at the meeting Frank Vanderlip
who was the number two at National City
Bank and Henry Davidson who was one of
the senior partners at the Morgan Bank
actually presented the plan to
Washington which I do not know either
this was something I discovered in the
book so it wasn't even the bankers
planned this whole thing and were there
which they were they actually went to
Washington to present the findings the
actual Federal Reserve Act that was
passed ultimately under Woodrow Wilson
looked a little bit different from that
plan but it had a lot of love a lot of
similar aspects of it you know this idea
of a central bank the concession was
that there would be a New York Fed which
would be closed and has continued to be
close to the Wall Street banks and then
there would be the Federal Reserve on
which the president would appoint the
chairman and so there was kind of this
idea of a balance of power and everybody
was happy and there's a whole bunch of
stuff in the book about all the
maneuverings at midnight
1 a.m. in the White House until that
finally did get passed and signed under
Wilson I mean clearly the Federal
Reserve is you know a lightning rod
especially currently given a lot of the
quantitative easing programs that are
going on but right from its right from
its outset it's always been promoted as
an independent institution in your
opinion can it be independent you know
given the nature of the relationships as
you have laid out I mean exquisitely in
your book no it's it's it's really naive
to think it can be independent one
because the very structure has member
banks within each of the Federal Reserve
Bank's serve owning shares in the
Federal Reserve as a full entity so
that's number one there's sort of an
even ownership type of relationship
there but beyond that the philosophical
relationship which is really the strong
one that started back in Jekyll Island
and has gone through today its art
actually Benjamin strong was the first
head of speaking of strong in New York
Fed he was one of the guys who had been
at Jekyll Island so he got to be head of
the New York Fed and Paul Warburg who
was another of the men that was at
Jekyll Island that meeting was appointed
by Woodrow Wilson to be one of the
governors of the first Federal Reserve
and from the beginning through through
World War one so so from the get-go
there was a connection between how it
was established why it was established
and the appointments that were allowed
and physically done by the president at
the time and that really hasn't changed
there's never been a suggested
appointment that's come through a
president that has not been accepted by
Congress who was supposed to have an
extra say in this it's always been a
very slam-dunk kind of situation Larry
Summers recently kind of took his name
out of the plate and other stuff
happened there but for the most part
historically every time a president
wanted someone at the helm of the
Federal Reserve it happened and from the
beginning these people tended to be
bankers particularly on the New York Fed
which is the most powerful
the Federal Reserve System remains a
fascinating topic and again all the
calls for transparency relative to
opacity so there's there's certainly
more that's always to be studied there
yeah and Bill Grider's book you know
secrets of the temple was something that
really inspired me I could have spent a
lot more time on the relationships in
the earlier years and the Fed but he did
such a exquisite job on that that I will
give him a habit where it has there you
go obviously having studied extensively
the the presidents as well as the
bankers in your opinion you know have
there been a couple of presidents either
who really stood out in your eyes being
truly you know magnanimous in their in
the way that they've executed their
office or you know on the on the other
end of the spectrum you know willfully
weak and in far too willing to turn over
the reins of power to the bankers well
back in the 20s you know before the the
crash in 1929 we had a succession of
presidents from Harding through Calvin
Coolidge through Herbert Hoover all of
whom just just allowed the two were
their friends also to do what they
wanted to do because they believed this
was important after World War one
not just for financial power but for
America's emergence as a political
superpower that if you had banks who
could expand who could you know
basically do what they said they needed
to do to become strong themselves and
that was good for America in general
which is actually a theme that continues
to exist through today then it was very
specific because of the post warrant was
the emergence of you know America the
superpower Calvin Coolidge did did
really nothing to thwart any of this I
mean he was famously talking about how
you know the business of America is
business but also his Treasury secretary
actually the Treasury secretary that
served for Harding and Coolidge and
Hoover Andrew Mellon was himself a
banker and himself believed that it was
important to allow
the banking community should do what it
needed to do which meant not having any
real rules and the ultimate result of
that was a tremendous amount of
speculation after World War one that
ultimately led to a tremendous crash
which ultimately led to a Great
Depression so so those presidents had
relationships but they they didn't
really try to use them to get anything
back from the bankers it just going so
de forward in history LBJ was someone
who didn't really come from the same
Eastern establishment societal
connections as as some of the main
bankers of his time but he was such a
master politician that he understood how
to sort of stroke the the personalities
and the positions of the people in power
in banking at the time as well as get
stuff done so he was very much a man
about you know I will yeah if he I will
pass I will or I will not you know I
will not restrict you I will not worry
about your competitors you know smaller
types of financial service firms who
think you have too much power I'm going
to I'm going to not play in any of that
I will let you do what you need to do
but you need to support my Great Society
you need to not say anything negative in
the press you know you need to be on my
side and that even continued into the
beginning of the Vietnam War there are a
lot of bankers who help raise money in
the beginning of that war they
subsequently turned against him and
things started to unravel towards the
end of his if his second term but he
just knew how to use the relationship to
work for a broader public interest as
well as allow the idea of a financial
strength to continue so he was very good
at doing that not having had as many
long-standing connections as someone
like FDR who also did a lot of that had
when he worked on his policies let's
stick with that topic there of the wars
in the 20th century we had the the two
great wars we had you know a Korean
crisis the Vietnam War as well but then
also the the the Cold War you know what
sort of a role did the banks and these
bankers play in terms of you know our
nation's involvement both pre and then
post war
yeah I mean it goes back to the Woodrow
Wilson Thomas Lamont relationship back
during the end of World War one well
first the Morgan bank itself worked with
Wilson and the Treasury secretary at the
time to finance seventy-five percent of
the private investment that went into
funding allies for war related arsenals
and so forth so there was already a very
strong alignment between the Morgan Bank
and the White House very regular very
much an idea of that money that needed
to go into the war effort was going to
be consolidated through through the
private bank and then of course there
was war bonds where individuals across
the country were asked to invest in the
war invest in America and so forth and
ultimately that help banks grow because
they had new customers after the doors
and in Second World War they sort of
tried to do the same thing there's some
different people at the Helms of the
major banks and at this point when
through Baldrige who was running Chase
really stepped into the forefront
because of his relationship with FDR and
the Chase Bank became as well as
National City Bank there was a
relationship with a vice chairman of
National City Bank Burgess with Morgan
Bao who was the Treasury secretary under
FDR during World War two that allowed
these institutions to continue private
financing of the war but also a much
larger blanket approach to getting
individuals to buy war bonds and take
out accounts in these banks at the same
time so that was the way they sort of
combined helping the country expanding
their presence and getting new customers
but then by the time you got to the Cold
War all these new customers are there
and the policy of America under Truman
and under Eisenhower was to make sure
that communism could not prevail
basically throughout the world and that
capitalism would be the dominant ISM and
in Eisenhower's doctrine he basically
states that you know America would stand
ready to to fight from a military
perspective or an economic perspective
or what he said was a trade perspective
in order to protect its its allies
effectively the ones that were on the
suit of capital the side of the equation
that
really help the bankers because now of a
sudden they have military support to
expand their branches into these
countries and as a result of the
beginning of the Cold War they expanded
into Cuba before Castro came in and
nationalized the banks out of Cuba they
expanded into Beirut because that was
going to be a stronghold at one point
into the rest of the Middle East and all
of this was done with the protection of
the US military so the whole idea the
whole reason the international aspect of
banking happened particularly with these
major banks was the connections that
they had into presidents and policies
and they also were on the pulpit to
promote these policies winthrop aldrich
went around the country talking about
the Truman's Marshall Plan and helping
and aiding countries that were on the
side of the US and so forth and open
trade and free trade so there was a
there is an extensive alignment amongst
people that knew each other and have
similar interests and used each other to
expand truly fascinating stuff I mean so
you talk about that sense of alignment
and you know clearly coming out of the
depression there was this you know this
anti banker you know look what you just
did to us in terms of speculation you
know working our way though into World
War 2 where this this sense of
collaboration and you know now it seems
to have come full circle again so I mean
it's this this cycles these ups and
downs you know are the bankers in your
opinion though at you know trying how do
they balance that that that profit
motive and incentive versus you know
national interest
yeah and that that is a big cycle that
was something that was very interesting
to me in the book I mean the fact that
that Alger's was working with FDR for
example to pass the glass-steagall Act
which tremendously reformed banking and
reduced the ability of banks to
speculate with other people's money with
depositors funds was was really
interesting to me because you wouldn't
assume on the surface that would happen
but under the surface it does make sense
because if we have a more stable economy
for everybody then a banker who
understands that that is a
surely good that a ground-up stability
is actually good not just for the
country but also for his bank actually
wins in in the profit stakes because
yellow today JPMorgan Chase is the most
powerful bank in the world certainly the
most powerful bank in the United States
so the fact that Winfred Eldridge pushed
his bank to be split up in the 30s
because he yeah one on one hand you want
to take over his his his competitors and
sort of be the guy and have the bank
that did that and have the government
backing but on the other hand it worked
JPMorgan Chase exists today so so that's
sort of gamble that profit motive worked
out but but also these guys were you
know Aldredge lamont these guys were out
in Europe we are doing food drives and
and trying to lemon spent a lot of time
trying to raise money in Congress after
World War Two to help the Chinese who
are impoverished and so forth so there
was a really different mentality of what
you could do for your country
as well as balancing what you wanted to
do in terms of your own power and your
own profit from from from the banks and
working together with with presidents to
sort of have everyone aligned on the
same page well today what we have you
know several decades of the dissolution
of this in between is nothing remotely
like that you can't imagine you know
Jamie Dimon going off and running food
drives leaving his post for months to to
help anyone you know so it's it's a
really different form of patriotism
existed than versus not existing now and
also it's not demanded from the
presidency you know then there was this
idea of I'll do this for you I'll open
markets for you do this for me this will
be good for the country with mistakes
along today and now there there isn't
even an expectation there was an
accountability there isn't a demand to
have that kind of a relation well to
that point I was there you know a point
in time where you you sensed or good
pinpoint where the the balance of power
shifted in these relationships yeah I
was it was there was two points it kind
of happened I think in two stages one
after this period of
between FDR through through Eisenhower
where the the needs of what the
political needs and the financial needs
and the individuals were all on the same
page and very closely connected and in
conference and everything you had JFK
come in and of course he did a family
basis he certainly had relationships
with the people that were rising at the
major banks but his a little bit sort of
standoffish about the idea of asking
them for favors okay and as a result
they weren't as nice to him publicly in
fact in 1962 David Rockefeller wrote a
very sort of they had a famous set of
letters that were published in Life
Magazine between medieval rockefeller
and JFK where on the surface they look
like they were being collaborative but
actually if you read the the text it
sounds like David Rockefellers is kind
of critical of some of the initiatives
of of JFK in particular with respect to
Latin America JFK didn't want to fully
have Latin America open to the private
interests of individual companies he
thought that they should be strong
rather than you know simply pushing
their leaders to be open whereas David
Rockefeller and another Walter Wriston
and people that were coming into the
folds of the major banks at the time saw
this is a tremendous opportunity and he
had cheap commodities it was right next
door
branches were going up left and right
and they really wanted the government to
support much more of their private
endeavors and JFK kind of thought that
Latin America should be strong on its
own so there that was kind of a
divergence but then of course he was
assassinated and LBJ came in and as I
mentioned before LBJ had this first of
all he was much more about to the
private interests International and he
much more supported what the bankers
wanted to do and he had many more
personal he knew how to stroke their
egos too there was a lot of invitations
a lot of back and forth between Weinberg
between David Rockefeller between
members of National City Bank in and out
of the White House you invited to his
ranch he he had these monthly elite
dinners
in Washington where he would invite very
particular members of the financial and
other types of business communities to
make them just feel like they were all
on the same side and actually even after
Kennedy was shot and LBJ came into power
there was there was tremendous support
he had more public support in the press
and on Wall Street to help because they
thought that he would be supportive of
what they wanted to do so again it got
back to connected Nixon was a bit more
like JFK which a lot of people don't
wouldn't say but from from from the
standpoint of you know this this
collaboration he didn't want any part of
that it two points during his presidency
for example though he did suggest that
David Rockefeller should become Treasury
Secretary and Walter Wriston should
become treasurer ask them to become
Treasury secretaries they both said no
they're busy expanding their their Helms
but also get an ask them personally you
know where's LBJ we'll get on the phone
and have an invitation have a dinner
inviting to the White House bill buddy
buddy and how's your daughter doing have
you just didn't do that and at that
point they had gotten together and
thought all right well we can take
policy from here and they actually push
Nixon and people in his cabinet to get
off the gold standard which which
happened in the beginning of Nixon's
presidency and all sorts of other things
that now they started making demands
without feeling they needed to to give
anything in return and I could go
there's a lot of stuff on the book you
know that that then devolves into Middle
East oil and all sorts of other things
that came out of that disalignment got
it so was it was it your sense you know
at that point in time that the bankers
felt you know what I actually have more
power where I'm currently situated then
one might think that they would have in
whether it says the head of Treasury or
elsewhere in Washington yeah that was
exactly yet they were they had just gone
through this expansion they were still
going through it there was consolidation
in the banking industry because no none
of the presidents that got in the way of
having that
consolidation and concentration happened
so it was much more lucrative from power
and influence as well as a money
standpoint money wasn't even really the
thing it was more about the influence
and the power to not have to work on
sort of a public international interest
and and having having access to petrol
dollars to oil the Middle East in the
70s was also big point of departure in
this because all of a sudden you don't
necessarily need the backing of the
military to open up branches you just
have all this extra money that you can
then refund all around the world which
it turned out went into the form of debt
and Latin America and ultimately caused
a third-world debt crisis which was
bailed out by the government so it
started to really dissect yep yep yep
let's stick with that theme right there
this this whole concept of bailouts
obviously and we had the massive bailout
in 2008 and the American public is you
know never again we you know we can't if
we can't do that you know just stay away
from it and in Washington promotes with
taking care of that so you know we'll
never have to have another bailout 2008
was not an individual event and we've
had weather is the the bailout of Penn
Central the bailout of third-world debt
savings and loans Mexican bailout
long-term capital management can you
talk about the the role that you know
all those bailouts had in terms of
behaviors within these banks
yeah those those bailouts were really
open invitations to have another crisis
because if you if you risk money and it
either isn't yours to begin with to take
that risk or you know someone else ie
the government is going to the taxpayers
it's going to have your back and your
consolidating and merging and increasing
your your base of deposits and of
capital you can work with because you're
getting more and more citizens money in
as well you tend to do things that are
stupid and then a reckless and that are
illegal and or some combination of those
things and the SNL crisis
was an example of deregulation in
certain types of financial instruments
and services that enable lots of
speculation at the time in mortgages as
well which we saw repeated in the
subprime crisis more recently but the
third-world debt crisis was showed
bankers that they could they basically
Stonewall Washington and said you know
we have all these billions of dollars on
the hook these countries are right next
to us if you don't help us if you don't
help the World Bank which is supposed to
be an independent institution help us
everything's going to go to hell and the
American people will suffer and so this
idea of you know if you don't help us
the Americans will suffer so help us but
we won't help back there you know was
manifested by all of these of all of
these bailouts and by presidents from
Reagan through Bush through Clinton
through Bush through Obama who just
really got on board with that and we
continually play that card that you know
help us so that we can help them yeah
help us so we and that obviously doesn't
happen and we're still bailing out the
big six banks in particular because the
way that the Federal Reserve works the
quantitative easing the fact that the
Federal Reserve continues to buy
securities from these banks supposedly
and we like six years almost after this
crisis happen that's that's a tremendous
amount of help I'm the government they
are was helping everybody sort of pay
their mortgage instead of by mortgage
securities from the banks it would be a
very different stability in the overall
economy rather than of the big banks
yeah well then let's let's compare and
contrast then if we could the the
regulations that were put in place back
in the 1930s post the the 29 crash
verses what we've seen here post the
2008 crash with dodd-frank
what's your take on that right well the
glass-steagall Act that was passed in
1933 after FDR came to power was a very
clear line between the speculative
versions and services and things that a
bank could do and the deposits it took
and the services it provided to regular
individuals and small businesses there
was a very very clear distinction one
does not connect and as I mentioned
before the key bankers of that time two
of them actually went through budgets I
mentioned in James Perkins also a friend
of FDR's who came in to run National
City Bank after his predecessor Charles
Mitchell was such a crook also it was on
the same page as FDR was it well the
fascinating like things I found in the
research in the FDR papers was that they
had meetings
James Perkins was at the White House
three days after the inauguration
talking to FDR about how he would split
up his bank first he would tell his
shareholders this is how it's going to
go hmm and he did and so did Aldredge
before the glass-steagall Act was
actually signed in the summer 1933 so
that's what happened there was a fine
line between bedding and traditional
services the bankers were on the same
side as FDR the population was on the
same side as FDR and and things became
stable for many many decades several
decades after that you contrast that to
what happened in the wake of the 2008
crisis which has been a much more
expensive crisis for the general economy
for the actual unemployment level not
the sort of tagline unemployment level
for what was lost to individuals
throughout and relative to the bailouts
and subsidies that have been given since
and dodd-frank came along and did
nothing remotely like dissecting
speculation from depositors and
traditional banking activities deposits
and loans nothing it's really really
long it has lots and lots of pages yeah
and it does absolutely nothing
significant it's a huge difference
where's do we have the political will do
we have the lead do we have the
leadership in your estimation in
Washington to take on that battle no I
mean we have President Obama base
oddly said it was sweeping reform so if
you can look at something that is not
sweeping reform and compare it to
something that FDR did which was
sweeping reform and say that sort of
with a straight face and have your
Treasury Secretary Tim Geithner say that
with a straight face then no we don't
have the leadership that either would do
anything hasn't done anything to
stabilize a situation yet it's
pretending that it has which is actually
more dangerous than not doing anything
sure and I don't see anyone really
coming into play right now in terms of
you know the potentials we have or that
are being debated in terms of who might
run for president in 2016 that would
change that at all so we we don't have a
leadership that that is asking something
of those relationships even if they're
less tight even if they're less about
you know family connections even if they
have more lawyers and lobbies lobbyists
in between there's no demanding and
there's no giving because there's no
demanding well that's a dangerous
proposition exactly at the Wow truly
incredible just a couple quotes from the
book what's your take on on the
following quotes first first off he
controls the money supply controls the
nation this is what we have right now
with the big six banks today we have a
money supply that the Federal Reserve is
technically in charge of but what it has
done in its policy has it has bought
over four trillion dollars worth of
securities from the banks or Treasury
bonds that go through the banks back to
the Fed on which the Fed pays interest
to the banks so they have a say in rates
they've made rates close to zero percent
for the longest period in US history or
in the history of the Fed but the
control you know is retained by the
banks that get the money they receive
the assistance and you couple that with
the fact that today there is more
concentration of capital in the hands of
fewer banks and fewer bankers running
them and there's
ever been in our history and you're not
just controlling the money supply you're
controlling the capital 84% of the
deposits in this country that are
insured by the FDIC reside at the top
six banks eighty-four percent eighty
five percent of assets 96 percent of the
derivatives exposure six banks in the
United States they control forty five
percent of the derivatives exposure in
the world
that's a tremendous amount forget the
political financial phone calls to the
White House visits and invitations
that's a tremendous amount of capital to
be in charge
sounds like a powder cake it is and
again we've only emerged and when I say
emerge I mean we've only continued on
from the crisis of 2008 to have these
sorts of were statistics and we have
before and have big banks bigger than
they were before controlling more than
they did before and that's that's a very
very unstable scary prescient yes Gary
preposition obviously I mean the
elephant in the room in terms of too big
to fail yeah but what's your take on you
know too big to regulate prosecute and
Trust yeah too big too big to fall too
big to rein in um and and and as you
said before Larry no leadership yeah at
the highest echelons to do anything
about it
well that's very troubling in chapter 16
you write the quote this was the this
really grabbed me no longer was there
even a pretense of alignment with
domestic concerns or collaboration with
the White House so take that quote
relative to you know what we had coming
out of World War two
I mean that that's a pretty strong
statement yeah I don't remember if I
said that in the seven exactly what year
within the seventies that that quote
came from or that I was referring to but
but but but the fact is that that that
disalignment that we have used the
government for what it's worth we used
to have this sort of relationship where
we would give and there be a
give-and-take you know we don't need
that
we'll just we'll just take and the
government really receded into a
position of having less power as the as
the consolidation a capital became more
and more concentrated the power base
shifted back to Wall Street it had been
that way in the panic of 1907 that was
when Teddy Roosevelt had asked JP Morgan
to save the country the Morgan Bay even
in the late 1890s that the Morgan bank
had more money than the Treasury
Department we've come full circle here
we've come from Sun n it was like real
money it was like real gold it was real
money yeah now it's it's it's leverage
capital it's it's all sorts of more
complicated money and and and and with
broader power yes and it was back that
into that very point the the the power
and often times power is is equated with
oftentimes arrogance you know there's
one quote in the latter part of the book
that really grabbed me and some people
in the public have heard this this quote
that's why I'm richer than you yeah that
was a Jamie Dimon in an internal call
with some analysts at Chase and the
impetus for that quote and basically
just what it means I wanted what it says
is that you know this this isn't about a
greater good it's not about a public
interest it's not it's not about even a
profit motive being sustained by by
something reasonable it's about my ego
hmm and my money as it feeds my ego and
my power as it feeds my ego and and you
bring that into the equation and that's
just part of why it's it's also much
more dangerous now there was a fellow
who ran chase back in the 30s as well Al
Wigan who had quite a big ego and he was
chucked out okay when when Winthrop
eldritch came in under FDR and he didn't
work to run the bank anymore you know
and so there was a you know
that sort of existed after that
depression and into the worse that
doesn't exist whatsoever at all anyway
that's truly troubling early nineteen
hundred's we had these six large banks
you know dominating the marketplace we
still have now six large banks but in
the interim there have been endless
numbers of mergers has there ever been a
merger that you know that a major bank
hasn't liked I and whatever happened to
the Sherman and Clayton Antitrust Act in
the world of major banking yeah I make
it all goes back to that panic what what
happened after the panic of 1907 it was
very very significant because out of
that came as we talked about the Federal
Reserve and then when the world where
what happened Woodrow Wilson and it's an
interesting little story in the book
called Jack Morgan JP Morgan's son to
the White House after having campaigned
on this notion of breaking these money
Trust's that were run by people like
Morgan because there was a war coming on
and there's all sorts of speculation in
the press at the time you know why are
these guys getting together why is
Morgan at the White House what's Wilson
doing you know and it turned out a
couple months later that they were
trying to figure out how to finance a
war and they were very much on the on
the same page and and you know we now
have that situation where the there's
nothing to keep that page well it
clearly seems I mean with such as you
were just referencing you know the the
percentage of capital and deposits and
derivatives and assets in such few hands
that it allows for ultimately
manipulation and and scandalous
activities within the markets which is
why if you which is why you need actual
defined well defined structures to at
least be unquestionable and unlovable a
non-lawyer bull against in order to at
least create less risk yep to everyone
else in the general economy I mean that
should be a you talk about you a
government is supposed to protect
the citizens of the country well it's
not just about all the money spend on
military the government has and should
have a responsibility protect the
country from the standpoint of its
economic well-being and in a situation
where the concentration of wealth and
power and influence and capital is so
out of whack then a government that's
allowing that a presidency any
presidency that it's allowing that to
happen is not doing its best by the
American people is not doing what would
be best in the interest of a true
democracy well then the question begs
does it really matter who sits in the
White House
um yeah these these last several decades
it really has in front front from this
standpoint you know you talked about all
the various bailouts all the crises that
have happened in between internationally
between the third world debt crisis the
Mexican peso crisis the S&L crisis
domestically versus the 2008 crisis and
all of this continues to happen
regardless of whether there's a
Republican or a Democrat in the White
House regardless of whether the Treasury
secretary is a Republican or a Democrat
and who's running the Fed so it hasn't
mattered it hasn't mattered no me this
has been fabulous we've got though we've
got three or four minutes left here I
let's just touch upon let's try to look
forward to the future obviously a lot of
unknowns you know we're sitting here at
a point in our nation's history which
you know having come out of this crisis
of o8 kicked the can down the road lots
of issues what would you like to see and
how are we going to you know to make
that happen
I mean I'd love to see true leadership
coming out of the Oval Office with
regard to the issues we've been
discussing here today I would love to
see a return of the glass-steagall Act
not a pretend return of the
glass-steagall Act to at least create
structural reform because there will
always be lobbying and lawyering and
personal calls to ask for things a
little more balance between what's
required for the stability of the
country versus putting everything and
all the eggs
to the basket of stability for the
largest banking institutions and a real
strengthening of of America from that
standpoint that would be good to see we
be not good to see in other crisis which
is very likely what will happen instead
because these things aren't happening I
think there's a lot we can learn from
our history I mean it has some very bad
moments and it has some really decent
moments and I think that and that's one
of the things I found in this book you
know that the periods where things
worked better are things we should
accentuate like move up from there we
can criticize them but we should look at
them but the things that worked worse
for the general public we should try not
to do and that was really one of my main
takeaways from this book aside from from
the connections and just the anatomy of
how power relationships work between the
White House and Wall Street in this
country and how they impact policies on
a foreign and domestic basis but also
you know what makes sense for the
general public in the greater public
interest and do that more yeah well
regrettably it seems those who have
failed to learn from history are doomed
to repeat it and there's a lot that has
been repeated here obviously leading to
the you know the crisis of o8 in your
estimation will it take another crisis
to bring about some changes that we
haven't seen from this this most recent
one I think there's no way that won't
happen now whether we get the changes
after that crisis I I can't say but but
it's astonishing to me that what
happened wasn't enough and that the fact
that we are still subsidizing the the
banks that were involved was is is is
very incredible to me and truly we need
to be in a better place well know me I I
can't thank you enough the incredible
work that you've put into this book
you've done in my opinion a national
service and for those who you know
watching the show please read the book
share
with with you know friends family and
colleagues congratulations on a fabulous
piece of work thank you so much Larry
okay